my name is Mario rich I'm a professor of  astronomy at the University of  Washington in the Iraq Institute and  we're here at the University of  Washington the Iraq Institute in the  department astronomy  the skillset that mr. Oliver needs to  have to take advantage of these large  data sets so it used to be that to do  astronomy you have to be pretty good at  physics and mathematics and astronomy  itself understand the world around you  and the skies above you today when as  we're shifting towards these larger and  larger datasets our challenges there are  in many ways no different than those  facing Google or Facebook in mining  their datasets so basically we need to  have those kinds of skills data mining  software engineering programming those  are the kinds of things that now are  becoming a completely valuable part of a  data-driven astronomers toolbox